Pues fue un anuncio esperado por los
franceses y aplazado en varias ocasiones
debido a la polémica en torno a él y el
rechazo que suscita en un discurso
pedagógico con elementos claros y
aspectos concretos La Premier francesa
explicó el contenido de esta reforma
bajo tres premisas justicia equilibrio y
progreso es una reforma que eliminará
los llamados regímenes especiales que
básicamente son cerca de una treintena
de excepciones al actual sistema y que
usualmente se citan como injustas
desactualizadas y desordenadas además
promete Un aumento de las pensiones
importante la presentación de este
martes dijo Bond no es un punto final
porque El texto será sometido a debate
en la asamblea nacional pero un debate
bajo dos reglas tendrá que ser Leal y
constructivo según la premiere esas
condiciones ya hacen pensar en el pasado
cuando ella misma ha esgrimido la falta
de argumentos o de argumentos serios a
su juicio en los debates para cerrar la
puerta a las discusiones acto seguido ha
la aprobación de sus leyes que no apoya
al resto de los partidos en la asamblea
nacional al implementar el artículo
49:3 de la Constitución Habría que ver
si esto va a suceder nuevamente ahora la
de legislativo será una batalla pero no
decisiva porque el gobierno la puede
cerrar con un decreto el verdadero
desafío en este momento es convencer a
los franceses de que esa ley les
conviene y es ofensiva está lejos de ser
ganado Y cómo reaccionan los franceses A
esta modificación sabemos que se han
producido numerosas manifestaciones en
rechazo a lo largo de un buen tiempo
bueno las encuestas indican que cerca de
80% de los franceses se opone al aumento
de la edad de jubilación que es el
aspecto nuclear de esta reforma y ese
rechazo va a tener repercusiones en los
próximos días de entrada esta noche los
sindicatos ultiman los detalles de cómo
se organizarán contra esa iniciativa del
gobierno en ese sentido ha ocurrido algo
inédito todas las organizaciones
sindicales del país sin excepción están
de acuerdo en que la protesta social
tomar las calles es su último recurso
para presionar al ejecutivo O al menos
modificar la reforma propuesta Incluso
el líder de uno de los sindicatos
moderados del país la cfdt dijo que no
hubo entendimiento sobre el tema tras
reunirse con el presidente Emmanuel
macron de manera que las manifestaciones
huelgas y bloqueos que se esperan no son
una sorpresa desde el fin de semana los
servicios de inteligencia pusieron sobre
aviso al gobierno de que las condiciones
son propicias para el estallido social